Before March 2011, I was a photographic retoucher based in New York City.
We're pale, gray creatures.
We hide in dark, windowless rooms and generally avoid sunlight.
We make skinny models skinnier, perfect skin more perfect, and the impossible possible,...
...and we get criticized in the press all the time,...
...but some of us are actually talented artists with years of experience...
...and a real appreciation for images and photography.
On March 11, 2011, I watched from home, as the rest of the world did...
...as the tragic events unfolded in Japan.
Soon after, an organization I volunteer with, All Hands Volunteers, were on the ground...
...within days, working as part of the response efforts.
For weeks, all the volunteers and locals alike had been finding similar things.
They'd been finding photos and photo albums and cameras and SD cards.
Everyone was doing the same.
They were collecting them up...
...and handing them in to various places around the different towns for safekeeping.
Now, it wasn't until this point that I realized that these photos...
...were such a huge part of the personal loss these people had felt.
As they had run from the wave and for their lives,...
...absolutely everything they had, everything had to be left behind...
...and I was honored that day that they actually trusted me...
...to help them start hand-cleaning them.